herr präsident sie sie lieben und sie
arbeiten hier in ihrem amtssitz
verbarrikadiert hinter sandsäcken
gleichzeitig sind sie jeden tag präsent
über social media bei ihren landsleuten
und die ganze welt kennt sie
mittlerweile sie sind berühmt der name
selensky sagt quasi jedem auf dieser
welt etwas was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
wie hat dass die situation für sie
persönlich verändert
es fällt mir schwer ihre frage nicht
erwartet worden das sage ich ganz
aufrichtig
vieles hat sich geändert die werte ich
habe mich verändert unsere bürger haben
sich verändert das wichtigste ist in
unseren herzen als priorität geblieben
familie kinderstadt frieden in diesem
staat das sind die wichtigsten werte
sie haben gesagt sie haben sich
verändert wie haben sie sich verändert
was wie würden sie das beschreiben
ich glaube wir verändern uns alle nicht
wegen der umstände sondern wegen unserer
herangehensweise unserer sichtweise
darauf was gerade passiert
der krieg endet die haltung zu vielen
anliegen der krieg ändert die
herangehensweise aus den friedenszeiten
zu den kriegszeiten kann man
nachvollziehen dass man nur wenig zeit
hat man hat wenig zeit als mensch man
ist rund um die uhr mit dem krieg mit
der arbeit beschäftigt
das habe ich eingangs erwähnt man hat
keine zeit für die familie und die
kinder und versteht dass man die
freizeit die man mal hatte nicht
geschätzt hat wenn ich einschlafe denke
ich darüber nach was ich sonst noch
machen könnte damit dieser krieg zu ende
geht und wenn ich aufwache denke ich so
gott will sind in dieser nacht möglichst
wenige menschen ums leben gekommen
das heißt die werte die ich in der
ersten antwort erwähnt habe und das was
ich denke die gedanken haben sich
geändert die prioritäten haben sich
geändert so ist es
der präsident ist in friedenszeiten eine
person die gewählt wurde und ergebnisse
liefern soll
dafür hat man so viele stimmen bekommen
man versteht diese hohe verantwortung
es gibt aufgaben in der wirtschaft im
energiebereich ja es gibt aufgaben jeder
krieg verursacht hat ein präsident zu
kriegszeiten ist etwas mehr als ein
präsident für menschen
menschen verlassen sich mehr auf den
präsidenten als auf sich selbst wie in
friedenszeiten menschen denken ans
überleben und nicht an das
wirtschaftliche wachstum einer familie
deshalb verlässt man sich mehr auf den
präsidenten für menschen ist es ein
symbol
des zusammenhalts
man versteht als eine gesunde und
adäquate person welche verantwortung
dahinter steht diese verantwortung ist
unterschiedlich meine verantwortung als
präsident in friedenszeiten und meine
verantwortung als präsident in
kriegszeiten ich verstehe dass diese
verantwortung größer geworden ist
der us präsident joe biden hat jetzt
gerade gesagt er habe schon viel früher
gewarnt vor einem russischen angriff auf
die ukraine aber auch sie hätten es
nicht hören wollen haben sie
rückblickend etwas was sie anders machen
würden wenn sie zurückschauen
ich glaube dass die ukrainische seite
eine frage stellen sollte und diese
frage sollte an viele europäische
staatschefs sowie an den amerikanischen
staatschef gerichtet sein
es wäre gerecht wenn man auf mich als
ukrainischen staatschef im voraus gehört
hätte
wovor wir gewarnt haben ich meine
präventiv sanktionen damit der krieg
nicht beginnt die präsentation unserer
strategie bezüglich des schwarzen meeres
des
aufbaus der schwarzmeerflotte mit einem
partnerland
wir haben das vorgeschlagen wir haben
gesagt dass russland das schwarze meer
blockieren wird
wir haben auch über das raketenprogramm
gesprochen ich habe vor einem jahr
darüber berichtet und das programm
präsentiert
was wir an luftverteidigung broich arm
und zu schützen und das ist die richtige
antwort auf ihre frage
wenn man mich doch gehört hätte hätte
die ukraine mehr chancen die invasion
der russischen föderation aufzuhalten
die signale die sie ansprechen sie waren
alle unterschiedlich schauen sie mal
wenn alles so passiert wäre wenn alle
die ukraine gewarnt hätten dass es
morgen zu einer flächendeckenden in
version kommt so stellt sich die frage
warum wurde der luftraum nicht
geschlossen warum wurden uns keine
waffen vor dieser invasion geliefert und
warum wurden keine vorläufigen
sanktionen eingeführt so dass der
präsident russlands präventiv
aufgehalten wird
so würde ich das beantworten lassen sie
uns ehrlich sein wir haben uns darauf
selbst vorbereitet am anfang hat uns
niemand unterstützt und nun bin ich
allen partnern dafür dankbar dass wir
unterstützung bekommen
unser des
us-präsidenten es gelassen sie uns über
das deutsch ukrainische verhältnis reden
warum ist die beziehung zwischen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und ihnen so
kompliziert
ich glaube es gibt eine gewisse skepsis
in der beziehung der führung
deutschlands der ukraine gegenüber
ich glaube nicht dass diese skepsis auf
bundeskanzler scholz zurückzuführen ist
ich glaube nicht dass sie neu ist
ein java ich glaube wir haben wunderbare
beziehungen zwischen beiden völkern
und recht gute beziehungen zwischen den
führungen beider staaten
aber ich glaube diese skepsis kommt vor
allem zum ausdruck wenn es um die
künftige mitgliedschaft der ukraine in
der eu und der nato geht diese skepsis
war leider auch in der zeit von
bundeskanzler scholz zu spüren es gab
diese haltung und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass sich diese haltung ändern wird
sowie das gerade aussieht
mit der zeit kann sie sich ändern
vielleicht würde es helfen wenn der
bundeskanzler tatsächlich nach kiew
kommt das will er jetzt in kürze bereits
zu tun er sagte immer wieder er möchte
nicht einfach zu einem fototermin kommen
um sie zu besuchen ich nehme an das
sehen sie ganz ähnlich was konkret
müsste es denn dann seien bei diesem
besuch mehr als nur fotos
wir möchten auch nicht dass er nur zu
einem fototermin kommt
er meint wohl wir hoffen auf die
militärische unterstützung der ukraine
seitens deutschlands ich glaube er meint
dass darüber hinaus erwarte ich dass er
uns persönlich unterstützt und dass er
persönlich zuversichtlich ist dass die
ukraine der eu angehören kann und dass
der status eines beitrittskandidaten der
ukraine bereits im juni verliehen wird
wir rechnen sehr damit ich rechne er
damit dass herr scholz diese zuversicht
in seiner antwort zum außen jahren
es gibt aber auch die frage der
sanktionen die finanzielle unterstützung
die die ukraine braucht und alle
sicherheitsfragen mit denen er sich
bestens auskennt
was erwarten wir im zusammenhang mit
seinem besuch ich würde gern das
folgende wichtige anliegen präzisieren
wir brauchen von kanzler scholz die
sicherheit dass deutschland die ukraine
unterstützt er und seine regierung
müssen sich entscheiden
es darf kein spagat versucht werden
zwischen der ukraine und den beziehungen
zu russland
sondern
man muss für sich wählen wo man die
prioritäten setzt
ich glaube das deutsche volk hat das für
sich selbst entschieden der führung
fällt es schwer denn es gibt viele
verschiedene herausforderungen
ich kann das nachvollziehen trotzdem
rechne ich sehr damit
das heißt sie glauben die deutsche
bundesregierung sucht immer noch eine
balance zwischen russland und der
ukraine
es gibt viele wirtschaftliche
herausforderungen und sich für eine
seite zu entscheiden fällt einem schwer
weil es schmerzhaft sein wird es wird
wirtschaftlich schmerzhaft werden
unabhängig davon ob man sich für die
ukrainische oder für die russische seite
entscheidet
wenn man den weniger schmerzhaften weg
wählt ist es eine falsche
herangehensweise
das meine ich ich glaube man sollte sich
dafür entscheiden wo es war gibt rechte
des menschen das recht auf die freiheit
und die souveränität des staates und das
völkerrecht ich glaube das ist wichtiger
als diese oder jene wirtschafts
priorität
niemand liefert waffen in ähnlich großem
umfang wie deutschland das tut an die
ukraine sagt der bundeskanzler
stimmt das aus ihrer sicht
management petrikowski ehrlich gesagt
der ist deutschland etwas später als
einige unserer nachbarländer dazu
gekommen was die waffenlieferungen
angeht das ist eine tatsache
das ist nicht nur rhetorik sondern auch
eine tatsache die ersten die uns zu
helfen begonnen haben hat waren die usa
die slowakei polen großbritannien das
waren die ersten die geliefert haben
bulgarien und rumänien haben auch
geholfen
es ist klar warum das so gekommen ist
hat auch baltischen staaten sie gehörten
zu den ersten unter diesen staaten in
europa waren deutschland und frankreich
etwas später dran und das ist die
wahrheit sie haben die ukraine
unterstützt sie haben gleich erklärt
dass dies eine verletzung der
souveränität darstellt politisch haben
sie das gleich mitgetragen aber damals
am anfang des krieges brauchten wir
nicht politik sondern hilfe
anschließend kamen andere staaten dazu
und gott sei dank dass sie dazu gekommen
sind und uns helfen was den umfang an
gelieferten waffen angeht bin ich nicht
bereit die aussagen zu bestätigen die
sie eben gemacht haben ehrlich gesagt
ich bin mir nicht sicher die zahlen
herr präsident wir haben gestern mit dem
chef der ukrainischen eisenbahn
gesprochen der stellt sich und sein
unternehmen noch auf jahre des krieges
ein das ist keine frage die viele
menschen umtreibt in deutschland aber
natürlich auch in der ukraine sind wir
dem ende des krieges jetzt näher als dem
anfang aus ihrer sicht oder ist es
umgekehrt an diesem 110 tag
es fällt mir schwer etwas dazu zu sagen
war es nicht an mir oder an ihnen lied
zu sagen wann dieser krieg zu ende ist
es liegt an der bereitschaft der
russischen föderation den krieg zu ende
zu bringen und ihre bereitschaft hängt
von der stärke der ukraine ab
je stärker die ukraine sein wird je
besser wir bewaffnet sein werden umso
schneller werden wir vorangehen
je früher wir noch schneller vorangehen
können und russische truppen von unserem
boden verdrängen umso schneller wird
russland bereit sein den krieg zu
beenden
sie zählen die opfer nicht der
russischen regierung ist egal wie viele
menschen ums leben kommen uns ist es
nicht egal
ihnen ist es egal wie lange dieser krieg
dauert denn sie verdienen im grunde
genommen durch ölprodukte durch
energieexporte und ist all das nicht
egal wir zählen alles und tut es sehr
weh denn unsere menschen ums leben
kommen je schneller die ukraine gestärkt
wird je schneller europa in den
sanktionen geschlossen auftritt im
russland von großen finanzströmen
abzuschneiden unsere schwächer wird
russland sein
dann fängt man an nachzudenken jetzt
überlegt man sich nur wie man an der
macht bleibt und dafür braucht man die
unterstützung des volkes im lande wenn
menschen sehen werden wie viele
russische soldaten auf unserem
territorium ums leben gekommen sind wenn
menschen nicht die finanzmittel
ausgezahlt bekommen die sie heute
ausgezahlt bekommen wenn russische
unternehmer handlungsunfähig gemacht
werden verstehen sie dass es folgen
einer operation gibt
momentan sind die folgen dieser
besetzung für sie noch nicht so
bemerkbar
sie denken nur an ihre macht und an
ihren geldbeutel und das ist alles alles
ist recht zynisch
wir haben mit einer persönlichen frage
begonnen ich würde gerne mit einer
persönlichen frage auch enden sie haben
gerade gesagt
dass es ihnen nicht egal sein kann wenn
menschen sterben wenn sie hohe verluste
haben jetzt hat die ukraine aktuell an
der front sehr hohe verluste mich würde
interessieren wie sie diese sehr sehr
schwierige entscheidung treffen
sie könnten ja auch sagen wir ziehen die
front ein wenig zurück dann müssten sie
möglicherweise gebiete abtreten auf der
anderen seite könnten sie vielleicht
verluste ein weniger vermeiden ist das
etwas was in ihrem kopf jede nacht jeden
tag abgewogen werden muss oder wie sie
damit um
sie haben mit einer privaten frage
darüber angefangen wie ich mich geändert
habe wie sich alles geändert hat
nun beantworte ich diese frage auch an
dieser stelle
ich habe keine zweifel dass wir korrekt
an
und das ist das wichtigste
die veränderungen die ein präsident zu
friedenszeiten durchmacht und die ein
präsident zu kriegszeiten durchmacht
da darf es keine zweifel geben gar keine
man muss handeln
die zeit spielt dem feind und nicht uns
in die hände
was ist die wahrheit die wahrheit ist
wir sind auf dem eigenen boden das ist
unser volk
das ist unser territorium und es tut
sehr weh menschen zu verlieren das ist
so aber wir werden alles verlieren wenn
wir russland in diesem krieg unterlegen
sind
das wichtigste was mich von mir früher
unterscheidet ist ich suche keine
balance wie man eine balance findet um
irgendwie zu einem abkommen zu gelangen
wir wissen genau was wir tun ich betone
wir haben keine zweifel wir sind nur
dann bereit gespräche zu führen wenn die
andere seite bereit ist dem krieg ein
ende zu setzen wir haben keine zeit für
gespräche die nichts bringen
vielen dank für das gespräch
auch ihnen vielen dank kommen sie auch
in friedlichen zeiten nach kiew es ist
wichtig dass sie in kriegszeiten hier
sind und es ist sehr wichtig das
kasseler scholz in kriegszeiten
hierherkommt
das unterstreicht die unterstützung der
ukraine
davon gehen wir eigentlich aus